the party was on and yes there was some
big big energy in the building
energy give it up for the bt awards best
new artist
winning her first ever b-e-t award lotto
has all the feels i said i wasn't gonna
cry y'all i'm so grateful if you know me
and my story it's been a long time
coming i'm so appreciative my first
award
[Music]
and now her first performance with a
little surprise the divas are in the
building
[Music]
and that wasn't the only surprise of the
night right jack harlow blacks in the
mail peak season shout out to my ups
workers making sure i received it
remember the time jack wasn't quite sure
who brandy was while appearing on the
hot 97 radio show who's ready sisters
[Music]
and while jack's confession definitely
blew up the internet it's safe to say
the rapper is a lot closer to brandy now
after this b-e-t mike dropped allow me
to reintroduce myself
the collab we never knew we needed and
while jack's friend and collab partner
lil nazex was seemingly snubbed from the
nominations jack is still showing
support for his pal yep that's little
nas x on his shirt let's check on the
kids we got future doctors lawyers plus
a couple tennis stars in this house also
taking in the red carpet king richard
stars laila crawford and danielle lawson
where their co-star will smith nab best
actor my favorite moment was watching mr
will haul down an ice cream truck and
buying out the whole ice cream truck so
that the cats and the crew and even the
people in the neighborhood in compton
could have ice cream the stars were also
out to celebrate sean diddy combs who
was honored with the lifetime
achievement award take it away kanye to
see puff in real life i just need to
meet this man
this is my favorite artist
while it was a night of celebration many
stars also used the stage to share their
thoughts over the supreme court's recent
decision to overturn roe versus wade
including host taraji p henson it's
about damn time
we talk about the fact
that guns
have more rights than a woman